que je suis et je regarde d'ouvrir la
caméra derrière la caméra
ok ça fera un espèce de contrechamp face
comme quoi je suis du métier les gages
connaît m'appelle jean pascal j'ai 38
ans et je suis en colère je suis en
colère parce que la situation des noirs
dans ce pays elle est catastrophique
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
d'organiser le 27 avril prochain une
grosse marche de protestation noir place
de la république
ce sera celle du peuple noir de l'homme
noir de l'homme digne l'homme blanc doit
comprendre que le y'a bon [ __ ]
c'est fini c'est terminé mais t'as pas
sorti les affaires de la machine du coup
tous attendent deux secondes je suis en
train de faire un truc important ils
sont arrivés là sa fille mais je sais
mais il faut aller chercher une femme à
l'école quand même fouet aux états unis
il ya une martin luther king en afrique
du sud nelson mandela
si en france la personne d'hiver durera
jean-pascal zadi